if you love the piano if you hear
something that the word virtuoso is this
not one of the glamorous words in the
world it's the world that it's a word
that has enigmatic overtones it is a
word that is complex it's a word that
has obsessed all of the great writers of
the piano how did this one do that how
did this one play that and Rex ahan
wonderful Chinese pianist will be
playing on the program and of our
release meant and extraordinary virtuoso
will be there and we'll be having music
will be having talk will be having
recordings of great pianists such as
Simone Ferrer doing Oh things that you
know only he could do and many
recordings within and I will be reading
wonderful little excerpts about what it
means to be a virtuoso and what is the
Grand Manor which is so much a part of
the idea of virtuosity and the literal
gentlemanly aspect of a world that was
once so extraordinarily glamorous headed
by Paderewski and Friedman and Hoffmann
and on and on phone every country